We're on problem 1.
A project scheduled to be
carried out over a single
fiscal year has a budget
of $12,600.
Divide it into 12 equal
monthly allocations.
So if we divide it by 12
how much are we going
to spend per month?
So that's $1,050 per month.
Right?
12,000 divided by 12 is 1,000.
600 divided by 12 is 50.
So they're going to spend
$1,050 per month.
At the end of the fourth month
of that fiscal year, the total
amount actually spent on
the project was 4,580.
So 4,580 after four months.
By how much was the project
over its budget?
Well, let's see how much
they should have
spent after four months.
So after four months
they should have
spent 1,050 times 4.
That's what?
That's 4,000.
4 times 50.
200.
That's how much they should have
spent after four months
if they were on budget.
They ended up spending 4,580.
So let's see how much
they spent too much.
They spent $380 too much.
And that is choice A.
Next question.
Question 2.
For which of the following
values of n is 100 plus n over
n not an integer?
We could simplify this.
This is the same thing as 100
over n plus n over n, which is
equal to 100 over n plus 1.
So in order for this not
to be an integer--
this is the same thing.
1 is clearly an integer,
so this can't
be an integer, right?
So we have to pick an n that
is essentially not
divisible into 100.
So what are their choices?
So they say 1.
Well 100 is clearly
divisible by 1.
You'll get an integer there.
So it's not 1.
2.
100 is clearly divisible by 2.
100 divided by 2 is 50.
That's not it.
3.
100 divided by 3.
That's 33.333.
That's not an integer.
So choice 3 will not produce
an integer if it's selected
for n, so we're at C.
The answer is C.
Next question.
3.
Rectangular floors x and
y have equal area.
If floor x is 12 by 18--
let me draw that.
This is floor x.
They say it's 12 by 18.
And floor y is 9 feet wide.
What is the length of
floor y in feet?
OK, I didn't have to
draw this, I think.
So floor y is 9 feet wide.
So they're saying it has the
same area, so essentially
they're saying that
9 times-- and they
want to know its length.
So let's call that l.
So the area of floor y, which is
9l, is equal to the area of
floor x, which is equal
to 18 soon. times 12.
And I even multiply this out,
because I don't know off the
top of my head what 18 times 12
is, but we can just divide
both sides by 9, and we get l is
equal to-- let's divide the
18 by the 9.
2 times 12, which
is equal to 24.
And that's choice E.
Next problem.
Problem 4.
A case contains c cartons.
Each carton contains b boxes and
each box contains c-- OK,
so c cartons.
OK, case is equal
to c cartons.
Carton is equal to b boxes.
And then they say a box is
equal to 100 paper clips.
How many paper clips are
contained in 2 cases?
So we could say 2 cases is equal
to 2c cartons, right?
So each carton has
how many boxes?
Has b boxes, right?
So this is going to be
equal to 2 times c.
Right?
That's how many cartons, and
each carton has b boxes.
So it's going to be equal
to 2cb boxes.
And then each of these boxes
is going to have 100 paper
clips, so times 100.
So that is equal to
200cb paper clips.
And that is choice C.
They wrote bc instead of cb,
but that's the same thing.
So that is choice C.
Next question.
Question 5.
The sum of prime numbers that
are greater than 60, but less
than 70 is?
So let's just think of them.
60 is not prime so that
doesn't work.
61 as far as I can
tell is prime.
Right?
I can't think of any numbers
that go into it, although
maybe I'm missing a few.
62 isn't prime.
That's even.
63 is 9 times 7.
That's not prime.
64 is 8 times 8.
65.
That's not prime,
divisible by 5.
66?
Nope.
67.
Is 67 prime?
Let's see, 67.
I think it is.
I can't think of any numbers
that go into it.
68 is not prime.
It's even.
69 is divisible by 3.
And 70 is clearly not prime.
So if I'm right, these are
the two prime numbers.
Let me make sure 61
is not divisible.
It's not divisible by 3.
It's not divisible by 7.
Yes, 61.
17 times 3 is 51.
Yes.
I can't think of anything.
So if we add these two numbers
up, I get 128.
So choice B.
I hope that's right.
Next question.
Question 6. you
A rainstorm increased the amount
of water stored in
state J reservoirs from
124 billion gallons
to 138 billion gallons.
If the storm increased the
amount of water in the
reservoirs to 82% of total
capacity, approximately how
many billion gallons of water
were the reservoirs short of
total capacity prior
to the storm?
So, let's see.
How many billions prior
to the storm.
So this is 82% of
total capacity.
So capacity is going
to be equal to 138
divided by 0.82, right?
Well, maybe I skipped a step.
Let me write that.
82% of total capacity
is equal to 138.
So you divide both sides by
82%, or 0.82, and you get
capacity is equal to
138/0.82, right?
And then they want to know how
many billions of gallons of
water were the reservoirs short
of total capacity prior
to the storm.
So it's going to be this
number-- this is total
capacity-- minus what they were
prior to the storm, 124.
So we just have to do a little
bit of mathematics.
I don't know if they allow you
to use a calculator, but I
think we can do this
on our own.
0.82 goes into 138.
And we could take this decimal
point two over, so we can move
this decimal point
two to the right.
So we get that there.
So it becomes 82 goes into
13,800 how many times.
So 82 goes into 138 1 time.
We get 6.
13 minus 8 is 56.
560.
82 goes into 560--
Well, let's see.
80 goes into 56 6 times.
6 times 82 is 12, plus 1.
6 times 8 is 48.
49.
And then we're left
with, let's see.
What is that?
This becomes a 5.
This becomes 15.
So we're left with 68.
680.
82 goes into 680 8 times.
8 times 2 is 16.
8 times 8 is 64.
65.
And you're left with, I don't
know, what is this?
24.
240.
So after the decimal it keeps
going, but the total capacity
is about 168.
So how short were they?
168 minus 124.
So 68 minus 24 is 44 gallons.
And that's choice E.
They give you a little bit of
hairy decimal problems. I
don't know if calculators
are allowed, but we
did it without one.
Problem 7.
Actually, I'm almost of time.
I'll continue this in
the next video.
See